joe biden será el candidato demócrata a
la casa blanca en la segunda noche de
esta convención poco habitual debido a
su formato virtual bailén recibió el
apoyo de la mayoría de su partido con el
objetivo de vencer a donald trump donald
trump dice que estamos liderando al
mundo bueno si somos la única economía
industrial que tiene una tasa de
desempleo triplicado en tiempos así la
oficina oval debería ser un centro de
comando en su lugar es un centro de
tormentas solamente hay caos pero no
todo el partido cerró filas en torno a
byd en los delegados más progresistas
dieron su apoyo a bernie sanders que
obtuvo mil 151 votos el ala más a la
izquierda del partido pudo demostrar así
su fuerza en su equipo en un momento en
el que millones de personas en eeuu
están buscando soluciones sistémicas al
desempleo a la falta de salud women and
white healthcare en el espíritu en el
espíritu del pueblo y desde el amor para
todas las personas
quiero nominar al senador bernard
sanders de vermont para ser el
presidente de eeuu de américa
tras la nominación la esposa del
candidato de un discurso
en torno a la unidad hay algunos que
quieren decirnos que este país ya está
dividido que nuestras diferencias no se
pueden reconciliar patatas no pero eso
no es lo que yo he visto en los últimos
meses porque nos estamos uniendo y
tomándonos unos a otros
encontrando la gracia y la piedad en
estos momentos que muchos dan por
sentado cuando internet
y hemos visto que las diferencias son
preciosas y nuestras igualdades
infinitas
muy hemos demostrado que el corazón de
esta nación aún está latiendo con coraje
anchorage el nuevo candidato tienen
previsto dar su discurso este jueves
último día de la convención